nadège bonjour alors quelle est
l'atmosphère sur place mais écoutez
olivier plutôt une ambiance cordiale bon
enfant ils sont plusieurs milliers de
manifestants réunis sur cette place du
trocadéro pour protester contre la loi
sécurité globale et particulièrement son
article 24 qui est très décriée par les
associations des droits de l'homme et
les syndicats de journalistes entre
autres ce texte on le rappelle est bien
puni de 45000 euros d'amendé d'un an de
prison toute diffusion d'image de
policiers ou de gendarmes alors le cas
le texte un cet article a été voté hier
à l'assemblée nationale en première
lecture de cet article a été modifié et
malgré la maladie la modification est
bien ce que réclament ces manifestants
et si c'est le retrait total de cet
article est de cette loi jugée
liberticide avec nous aujourd'hui pour
en parler dominique pradalié secrétaire
national du snj le syndicat national des
journalistes bonjour alors vous êtes co
organisatrice de cette manifestation
il ya beaucoup de monde a réuni sur
cette place du trocadéro qu'est ce qui
se joue clairement aujourd'hui pourquoi
demandez-vous le retrait de cet article
24 malgré la modification
hier et bien l'amendement de cet article
ce qui se joue c'est tout simplement
l'état de droit en france c'est à dire
la liberté d'informer la liberté de
filmer dans les rues la liberté de
rapporter en témoin ce qu'on voit tout
simplement or l'article 24 modifier ou
pas ne changera rien l'intention est de
museler la presse
l'intention est également d'empêcher les
cinéastes de faire leur travail de
documentation de la société française
gerin de dharmanand le ministre de
l'intérieur se défend un défend cet
article est dit que justement il évitera
qu'on jette aux pâtures qu'on jette les
policiers en pâture et que du coup ça
évitera les menaces de mort on est
d'accord que le code pénal déjà présent
interdit ce genre de choses ab
heureusement le le code pénal et la loi
de 1881 punit très sévèrement toute
atteinte qui sera portée aux forces de
l'ordre à des représentants de l'anc
elle qui soit heureusement que ça existe
donc le nouveau texte n'apporte rien de
plus si ce n'est la muselière pour les
journalistes
justement vous parlez de muselière pour
les journalistes gérald darmanin a
ajouté cette semaine que les
journalistes devaient se rapprocher des
autorités pour couvrir une manifestation
c'est du jamais vu jusqu'à présent dans
aucun pays démocratique on doit lever le
doigt pour demander si on doit
travailler comme journaliste
donc c'est une imbécillité grave
justement par rapport à cet article 24
face aux critiques le gouvernement a
tenté de faire de calmer le jeu il a
modifié amendé cet article en
garantissant justement la liberté
d'informer pour les journalistes sans
les bras suffisant pour non non non le
l'amendement gouvernemental ne modifiez
absolument pas l'intention de l'article
car voilà des beaux messieurs qui sont
dans leur bureau avec les pieds au chaud
ils sont jamais sur le terrain jamais
jamais jamais ils sont hors sol ils se
font dicter leur loi par les syndicats
de policiers les plus ultras or nous
avons vus depuis deux ans que la police
est en roue libre en france
la police est en roue libre c'est à dire
que le ministre dit quelque chose
mais la police fait ce qu'elle veut où
elle veut quand elle veut et on l'a
encore vu le
17 novembre dernier quand les
journalistes ont été tabassés mis en
garde à vue et c'est alors qu'on faisait
une manifestation extrêmement paisible
c'est une loi qui est très décrié et
puis on voit aussi qu'il ya plusieurs
membres du gouvernement de la majorité
mais mme la ministre de la culture qui
commence à se désolidariser de gérald
darmanin
oui il semblerait que le gouvernement
soit pas tout à fait d'accord
cela dit les députés votent comme un
seul homme tout ce qui passe devant mais
je ce que je trouve encore plus grave
c'est que l'onu les conseillers spéciaux
de l'onu pour les droits de l'homme ont
adressé à la france une très sévère mise
en garde
en douze pages en leur disant la liberté
de la presse à se respecte c'est
constitutionnel c'est internationale
c'est mondial
vous ne pouvez pas y toucher comme ça un
dernier mot et puis ce sera la fin au
sujet de la la mobilisation aujourd'hui
c'est plusieurs milliers de personnes
qui sont réunis aujourd'hui malgré la
crise sanitaire et le confinement mis en
place
oui des milliers des milliers de
personnes sont là parce qu'il ya les
journalistes et tous les citoyens
mais c'est vrai à paris c'est vrai dans
25 villes en france 25 villes en france
et le mouvement n'est pas près de
s'arrêter
ça vous allait poursuivre la
mobilisation jusqu'à la mobilisation va
forcément se poursuivre et puis
simplifiée effectivement malgré la crise
sanitaire jusqu'au retrait de ce texte
dominique pradalié merci 1 pour cet
éclairage merci d'avoir répondu à nos
questions vous l'avez entendu la
secrétaire nationale secrétaire général
du syndicat national des journalistes et
bien qui entend manifester protesté
jusqu'au retrait total de ce texte cet
article 24 qui est donc très décrié plus
généralement aussi cette loi je cette
loi de sécurité
blogue
donc qui cette protestation qui
réunissent et place du trocadéro
plusieurs milliers de personnes ici à
paris merci beaucoup n'avaient d'un job
à razac en direct de la place du
trocadéro à paris
on vous retrouve bien évidemment dans
nos prochaines éditions